in a quiet corner of Northeast Wales the
beautiful game has been sprinkled with
just a little Hollywood magic we love
the idea of telling the story of a
working-class town of a working class
Club because we feel like everybody
around the world can identify with that
in February 2021 non-leak site wrexham
association football club was bought by
the actors Ryan Reynolds and Rob
mcelhaney two and a half years later in
a story straight from the Silver Screen
they made it to the fourth round of the
FA Cup and secured promotion to League
two to the absolute Delight of fans
15 years we've finally done it I can't
believe it but what Robin Ryan have done
for us just unbelievable do you know
what it's not just about the football
club it's the community they've pulled
the whole area together
attendance at their games has soared to
ten thousand and the small site now has
some very big supporters many of them
overseas thanks in part to the
documentary welcome to wrexham which the
actors have been filming following the
club's rise since the Takeover
but as with cinematic epics for every
High there must be lows and despite
wrexham's success the club has lost
millions in its Pursuit already some are
asking what happens when Reynolds and
mcelhaney move on to projects new
eventually the documentary will end and
we have to make sure that what we've
built here is a story that will continue
I'm Neil Patterson and this is the Sky
News Daily
Mark Griffith says he fan and wrexham
Club commentator for the last 20 years
he also provides the voiceover for the
documentary series the fact is anything
can happen at wrexham at the moment and
it's it's mad but it's wonderful we will
be hearing a lot more from Mark in just
a moment but first i'm joined by Rob
Harris Sky's Sports correspondent uh so
Rob look it is a fascinating story
clearly but for those of us who aren't
as football Daft as you just explain
exactly what's been going on at wrexham
in the last few years well the Takeover
happened in 2021 and at the time it
looked like this injection of Hollywood
glamor into and that's the unglamorous
place I like wrexham don't be so
critical and you know we got word there
now it's potentially going to be a
documentary accompanying this so it
looked like actually some canny business
you're buying into a football club and
effectively you're buying a cast and not
just the cast of the team itself but the
entire city as well as rexton did become
a city in the last couple of years of
course and the way that they've used
that project has actually probably been
elevated beyond anything we could have
imagined but put it into context I mean
how much of a success how much of a turn
around has this been for the club well
they have had times when their own
future is in Jeopardy wrexham were down
in the lower leagues they have been
trying to rise back into the football
league into those four professional
leagues this is a takeover that has
given them that dream that ability to
get out of the National League because
it's pretty tough there's only one
promotion Place automatically from the
national league into League two by
comparison there are three promotion
places available from the championship
into the Premier League so the way
they've actually had to do it is pretty
challenging didn't get there in the
first season but they have spent their
way to gain promotion that was going to
be my question I mean to what extent can
we attribute the success directly to the
very significant we'll go through the
figures in a little while but the very
significant injection of cash that these
two Hollywood stars have produced well
you don't need as much cassay at the top
end of the game to actually make that
small bit of difference so Paul Mullen
the striker has scored 27 goals in the
National League this season
he's on repeatedly more than four
thousand pounds a week by comparison it
said actually the weekly average is
below a thousand a week internationally
so they are spending a lot more than
their Rivals to achieve this so it can
just be spending on players I mean you
do I know for example that they've
bought a stadium but presumably the
changes on the pitch are reflected by
changes in the back room as well yeah
exactly the fact the way they've
actually managed to get a sort of group
of players together the fact they've got
Phil Parkinson a manager who's
previously managed higher up in the game
he was attracted to this project too and
then it all comes together a lot of
things around football about the vibe
around the club if you've got a bad
atmosphere if you've got sort of an
unsettled sense of things then teams can
quickly go into a down downward spiral
as we do see so
it all comes together the fact you've
got a community behind the team you've
got a team with this purpose you're in
the Global Spotlight as well it's all
going to help sort of galvanize them and
that Vibe as you see can can maybe in
part be attributed to the new owners
themselves Ryan Reynolds and Rob
mcelhaney I mean there is something
almost quite romantic about these two
admittedly very rich and famous guys
buying the club and seemingly investing
not just their cash but their time into
it I mean they are figures people can
relate to and the fact they are
individuals rather than a nation-state
they're not a faceless Corporation or a
private Equity Fund that can buy into
sport maybe it harks back more so the
the way clubs were funded many years ago
often as the local businessman the the
local industrialist that was investing
you knew the person and and some people
will perhaps criticize them as being
sort of flamboyant trying to get the
publicity trying to be front and center
things but at the flip side we talk
about so often distant owners distant
foreign owners who don't engage with the
fans and these are owners who do go in
the pub yes in part it's probably to get
scenes for the documentary series but
they are there they're front and center
they're not just doing this from afar
they're not just in Hollywood they are
experiencing this community they are
helping to transform an area and even
just looking at the city it's not
somewhere has overloaded with tourism
with hotels and things like that so it
is a way of actually sort of breathing
new life into North Wales and actually
if you do
climb up the leagues as well that there
is that potential to sort of grow the
area because you get a bigger influx of
fans as well
Mark Griffis is a lifelong fan of rexham
he's also the club commentator it says
voice you hear doing the voiceover on
welcome to rexham and he's the host of
final whistle the wrexham AFC podcast
which I've just discovered it just so
happens to be the longest running footy
pod in the world I feel somewhat
intimidated now Mark look first and
foremost congratulations how did it feel
when you secured promotion well as a
wrexham fan and we're born
um I would say I realize we've done it
about 15 seconds before the end of added
time even though we were two goals of
the goods when I saw the referee Sidle
towards the tunnel and I thought he's
gonna put his whistling run off before
all the crowds get on I think until that
point I just couldn't take anything for
granted because it's just utter utter
Insanity because in fact I had a bit of
a strange moment when I was hugging
wrexham's captain on the pitch and as I
hugged him I looked over his shoulder
and I saw Rob mcelhenney arms
outstretched and staring manically at me
wanting a hug and I thought oh you know
I love this player do I really discard
him but in the end I gotta hug off both
of us I don't think I've it's quite sunk
into me that they bought the club in the
first place if I'm honest never mind
that this is happening what was the
reaction in rexham in and around the
club when the idea that you know
Hollywood actors Ryan Reynolds and Rob
mcelhaney we're coming to town and we're
serious about buying the club some
people were delighted because they just
wanted an outside investor other people
I'm include myself in this we have the
memories of twice going close to going
out of business a century and we were
very cautious when basically Ryan's name
leaked and when it did you you did start
to feel a bit more reassured and I think
a lot of people who were doubting
started to because the social media
profile is that of a right-minded decent
person who does decent things and that
gave you a sense of reassurance Rob come
when his name came out as well
you look at what he's stood for
throughout his life and you think the
last thing he's going to do is mess us
around so for some people it was an
immediate Delight for some people it was
a gradual process but by the time of the
votes where was it 96 of the members of
the member correctly voted to accept I I
think it's fair to say we'd all pretty
much arrive at the same energy and I
suppose no given the results given the
promotion uh Ryan and Rob if they are to
pop into a pub anywhere and wreck some
they probably don't have to put their
hand in the pocket exactly right
although to be frank usually if they are
going to pop into a bubble they've
probably already put 500 quid behind the
bar for everyone and that is the pattern
uh oh I must emphasize this to you this
is all about Community it's it's not
about Hollywood's and the people of
wrexham whether they're football fans or
not a acknowledge that they've genuinely
had a transformative effect on the town
and they did state that that was their
intention from the start because there
is a remarkable upturn in frankly the
self-confidence of the town I'm a
teacher honestly three years ago
kids from wrexham talking about wrexham
would have had a humorous
self-deprecating approach it was all
about you know the gwenville river
surging through what at least six inches
wise you know people were so negative
about Rags when we were suffering as
badly if not worse as the rest of the
country in terms of the economic
downturn and now oh I promise you
everybody wants to tell people they're
from wrexham tell me a little bit more
about this this idea that it's community
that is at the heart of what Robin Ryan
have been I've been trying to do because
of course as well as buying the club
there has been this documentary series
welcome to wrexham happening in parallel
with with the football well I think
actually welcome to raxum is
in some ways the way to explain it it's
also massively crucial to their plan
because they recognized that in a way
which I'm struggling to think of an
exact example where celebrity has been
converted into currency quite like
they've done this so welcome to rexham
as a key part of that because they
recognized they would have to find new
fans and they knew that the American
markets and the overseas markets drawn
in by their celebrity will be a key part
of it but what I think a lot of our
people looking from the outside don't
quite appreciate we have amazing
interaction with the international fans
they are wonderful but they are drawn in
by the community elements of the show
not the football they all say the same
thing we fell in love with the people we
fell in love with the town they they
enjoyed seeing the genuineness of the
people in the documentary and then they
fall in love with the football because
they wish well towards those people but
the key thing is that then a group of
them decided to make the ask wrexham
community group and their basic
intention is they want to give back to
wrexham just for the happiness they get
watching the show and they raise funds
which we help promote for local
charities because they want to feel like
part of the town which is I I'm I'm not
I don't feel I'm putting it in any
exaggerated way to say that for me
personally it's a genuinely uplifting
experience it's a genuine life enhancing
experience I I don't it sounds like I'm
an evangelist but it genuinely is
remarkable I'm I'm so happy to hear that
and so happy for you and and and the
other uh residents of wrexham it it has
been a roller coaster and it's ended up
in a fantastic place and it hasn't
stopped yet but I mean I've gotta I'm
gonna have to ask I mean what are they
like they are so lovely um I I'm I'm the
opposite to most people
um in that I had at the time of the
Takeover I've never seen a Ryan Reynolds
film I knew who was I knew he was
massive I'd never seen one but I'm a big
fan of Always Sunny in Philadelphia as
I'm a wife and my land so when we heard
Rob's name that was what blew our minds
I've had quite a bit of contact with Rob
which is fantastic obviously uh Fanboy
that I am
um the most amusing one was I they use
my commentary in the first season of
Welcome to wrexham and so he said he'd
fill me up so I'm sitting in my front
room my wife knows that he's gonna call
she's in a state of excitement my phone
goes off it says unknown number Beverly
Hills California I'm thinking I might
know who this is I pick her up my wife
while I'm speaking to be silently
dancing around me
and so I I said to him well I'm sadly
sorry I can't concentrate my wife's a
big fan and she's going mad and it's all
hand over the phone and they just had a
lovely 10 minute chat about it
um you know that that's something and
how he and his wife who's also a big
star as well and how they rescue cats
and it's just so lovely so how long do
you think that there will be I I suspect
the connection between the two and the
club will last the rest of their lives
but I wonder in terms of the ownership
how long that might continue
um I don't think anyone's really
thinking about that right now to be
honest with you
obviously you have got to be realistic
but you know both of them are very
explicit that they're in this for the
Long Haul they don't want to give us a
quick boost and then walk away
uh they may decide at some point they
could accept outside Investments which
would water down their their stake
obviously but that could be very
beneficial for us if they find a rich
person who wants to step in with them
but I I they really are I mean Rob said
to me on the pitch when I said just I
just I just said Thank you to him what
else could I say really and he just said
oh we wanted to start it now
[Music]
beautiful game it's May well be but
football is also a business and wrexham
have lost Millions close to three in
fact on top of that Rob mcelhenney and
Ryan Reynolds have loaned the Club close
to 4 million themselves now they say
there is no immediate pressure to repay
these loans but no one not even a
Hollywood star can keep shelling out
millions of pounds year after year
without at some point either wanting a
return on their investment or cutting
their losses so Rob what comes next they
are bringing new sponsors so that is one
thing that is actually being a benefit
of the series of the global appeal and
if you look at their sort of social
media posts they get huge interactions
huge number of views Beyond teams higher
up the league so there's an appeal for
sponsors which will bring in cash and
could ultimately bring in the interest
of external investors to perhaps to
dilute their our own share Holdings so
maybe it'd be seen as a candy bit of
business paying a couple of million for
this team in the fifth tier whereas in
the Premier League we talk about paying
billions for the teams and the beauty of
the system is if you can climb up the
leagues and you end up in the Premier
League you've got a big valuable asset
on your hands but they are losing money
and and on that basis I I do wonder and
I'm sorry I suppose the people of wrexon
will be questioning this as well just
how long the commitment of these two
Hollywood stars not from this part of
the world might well last so they won't
want to see their future jeopardize by
short term as in buying the pair of them
deciding actually we've had enough we've
achieved our success or perhaps we do
get into a situation where they're not
climbing the ladder of the English game
further and if we look at another team
Salford City a team that's being
transformed climbing up through the
leagues not organically but because of
the injection of cash from former
Manchester United players Gary Neville
David Beckham Paul scholes Ryan gigs as
well as a Singaporean investor Peter Lim
that's the cash that took them through
the pyramid it also led to investment in
their Stadium but they've been in League
two now for Four Seasons they're not
finding it easy to gain the next step
into League one so it shows even with
the investment that you are potentially
prohibited in terms of The Next Step you
can make and I wonder Rob whether any of
this would have happened if British
football wasn't as popular as it is now
in the United States like you can be in
any American city and there will be a
bar open on a Saturday morning showing
the game and you've got Ted lasso of
course that that very funny Apple TV
series about an American football coach
coming to the UK to coach English
football I mean Rob I mean are we likely
to see more U.S investment in UK
football it has been transformational
over the last decade in part due to the
growth of the Premier League on NBC
which shares the ownership of Sky News
of Comcast and they do show a match
typically once a week free to Air
nationally on the main NBC channel and
that gets notable viewing figures and
it's seen an American audience become
very closely associated with the Premier
League with soccer not seeing some
foreign entity then it explains them but
actually really engaging then you've
seen Ted lasso which started actually as
a character in an NBC promotion from the
Premier League and we've seen things
like Champions League competition
growing there on CBS with many of the
familiar pundits we know from the UK and
it's becoming part of the conversation
probably more so even maybe than their
own domestic Major League Soccer the
fact is there is this growing interest
in the Premier League which has seen
ownership come from the states as well
Chelsea's ownership the least American
owners into the Premier League so we are
seeing how soccer has just grown in the
state so everyone might want a piece of
the action tell me what on Earth is
going to happen to this club next year I
mean do you think they're going to
survive it's Synchro swim time isn't it
yeah I suppose one thing is about not
only
sustaining a competitive Challenge on
the pitch but sustaining interest in the
series how many series uh can it run for
you know if they do sort of stagnate and
drift around League two will people want
to keep watching does the value of that
series then diminish so it's not only a
football project but it's also a Truman
style project with everyone sort of with
the cameras looking in as well so you
need to sort of keep the the story lines
going as well so how much do they invest
in League two they are coming up against
sort of financial regulations as well in
those competitions so League two is
difficult but one thing is they can
attract players we saw with Ben Foster
the goalkeeper being signed by them for
the closing stage of the Season former
Manchester United's former England
International choosing to effectively
come out of retirement well there might
be other players who think worth me
joining Rex and because I'll get quite
Global standing as well in the series
and you can boost your own marketability
your own sort of post playing prospects
particularly if you're at the tail end
of your career and even just in the last
few days we've been seeing Gareth Bale
being perhaps uh
said by the owners on Twitter maybe it's
just sort of teasing but there's the
potential of players like that at the
tail end or have decided to step away
from playing thinking oh maybe I'll come
back for a bit if they want to boost
their profile although Gareth Bell is
not one of those players who's ever sort
of sought that sort of Fame and
celebrity side of the game do you know
what I think I might have found my
second Club Rob thanks very much indeed
oh well let's uh round off the podcast
with Super Fan Mark Griffiths and Mark I
want you to pop your wreck some
commentator hat on just for a second
imagine it is the end of the 2023-24
season and rexham are going up to League
one thanks to a goal uh from new signing
Gareth Bale what would the commentary be
like at that point I I think it would if
I'm honest just be a hybrid squeal and
then I collapsed and what a way to go
you know oh go on come on give it a go
pulls it back Ronaldinho with the dummy
Bill he says go
directly one here we come unbelievable
[Music]
my thanks to Mark Griffiths Rob Hallis
and of course Steve for listening to the
Sky News Daily with me Neil Patterson
this episode was produced by Rosie
Gillett with Alex Eden our editor is
Phillip
foreign